I want to leave behind a collection of
artifacts of my psyche psyche that
besides my own uniqueness has never been
collected before so that someone else
the psyche shaped similarly to mine can
see that black queer poor expressive the
assignment was to find a scene for your
type with a scene partner from a play
the assignment was to find a play
written by a playwright there were no
plays at my disposal that fell out of my
mouth with ease the words written in the
plays in my disposal did not fall out of
my mouth with ease so I brought in a
scene from a play that I had written I
wrote a play
that's when the seed was planted that I
could be a playwright
that I could write words that might fall
out of someone else's mouth Aziz
[Music]
more palpable to me the memories of um
mama and granny getting dressed for
church or memories of mom and Granny
getting undressed post church Sunday to
to preparing meals for family hats off
shoes off mama in a slip in a skirt me
up under her wigs in the bedroom or her
rough to keep it nice granny
calling me Chris
my youngest uncle's name and not Chris
I'm Jeremy I'm from South from Virginia
thing I love about the south so black
people know they're black people white
people
no they're white people
[Music]
[Music]
Celie now the color purple you've never
read the color mama no Whoopi Goldberg
later in the movie yeah Sarah Jane
Imitation of Life flinch wash regret
Nick desire Maggie the cat cattle Hot
Tin Roof this God is not true
every woman in a Bergman film every
woman in operator or vice versa Julianne
Moore in everyone
[Music]
you speak English
hello
the assignment was to find a scene for
your type with the scene partner from
apply the assignment was to find a play
written by a playwright the place of my
disposal did not fall out of my mouth
disease the words written in the plays
in my disposal did not fall out of my
mouth with beans so I brought in a scene
from a play that I had written I wrote a
fly
[Music]
you
[Music]